foreign
followers the people who choose to keep
up with your content on the Instagram
they are like your own personal
cheerleaders following you through every
post story and update you share do you
want to boost your popularity on the
platform you need those followers they
are the key to building your audience
increasing your reach and showing the
word what you are all about whether you
are a business influencer or just an
average user getting more followers is
the name of the game on Instagram from
clever hashtags to paid promotions these
are plenty of tactics you can use to
grow your following and become the Talk
of the Town so get out there and start
building your insta fanbase everyone I'm
Baba kandival and I welcome you all to
Simply learns YouTube channel today we
will be learning on how to increase
Instagram followers so first let me ask
you a question
that the Instagram get launched is it a
6 October 2010 or B 6 October 2011 or C
6th of November 2010 a d 6th August
2009. you can comment on your answers in
the comment section below now let's get
on with our session but before we get
into nitty-gritty of things let me take
you through simply learns professional
certificate program in digital marketing
or better known as postgraduate program
in digital marketing it is the
postgraduate program course by simply
learn in collaboration with Purdue
University and meta blueprint in digital
marketing this comprehensive program is
designed to equip you with skills you
need to excel in the fast space world of
digital marketing with this program you
will learn everything from fundamentals
of digital marketing to the latest
trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide you will explore
topics such as SEO sem content marketing
social media marketing email marketing
and much more
this program is led by Industries
experts who bring their real world
experience to the classroom giving you
an Insider perspective on what it takes
to succeed in the digital marketing
world
and with Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program
individual marketing is the perfect
place to start to learn more about the
course you can click on the link in the
description box below now without any
further Ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session
we will start off the discussion with
various steps to increase Instagram
followers moving forward we will also
discuss best practices to increase
followers
finally we will wrap this session with
the best tools to help get more such
followers so let's get started with a
few steps to help increase Instagram
followers first up you need to lay the
groundwork you need to identify your
ideal Instagram customers and create a
plan you can include keywords in the in
your profile and bio next you need to
create some interesting and engaging
content we have to craft a stunning
Instagram feed we can use lengthy
captions that are both engaging and
informative
then we have to make ourselves
discoverable
you can tag your location and other
relevant individuals in posts and use
hashtags to expand your audience
afterwards you have to be able to engage
with your community and build relations
you can start by collaborating with
similar companies and influential people
also you can interact with your
community and build trust and loyalty
finally you need to keep learning you
don't have to be afraid to use different
Instagram features and keep up with the
trends to stand out from others best way
to learn is to keep trying and keep
learning now let's check out some of the
best practices to keep in mind
in your Endeavor to increase followers
first up use relevant hashtags in your
posts and stories to reach a wider
audience next
you need to post high quality visually
appealing content that resonates with
your target audience
then we have to engage with your
followers by responding to comments and
asking questions
then we can also collaborate with other
users particularly those who have large
or engaged following
then we have to use Instagram features
such as deals and Instagram live to
share more personal and interactive
content next we have to utilize
Instagram speed promotion options to
reach a larger or targeted audience then
you can also consider using Instagram's
explore feature to discover and engage
with user who are interested in similar
content as to yours
afterwards we can also use Instagram
stories to share behind the scene
content and give your followers a more
personal look at your life or business
then you have to also post consistently
but you need to be careful not to flood
your followers feel
at last you have you can use Instagram's
analytics tools to track the success of
your posts and adjust your strategy
accordingly finally let's close this
session with the best tools to help get
more followers the First Tool in your
agenda is plan a pie
this tool allows you to schedule and
publish your post as well as analyze
their performance
the next tool we have is hoodsuit
this tool offers a variety of features
including the ability to schedule and
publish posts engage with followers and
track Analytics
then we have a tool called later this
tool is specifically designed for
Instagram and allow you to schedule post
track analytics and find relevant
hashtags
after that we have boostgram
this tool can help you to get more
Instagram followers by providing a
targeted followers through paid
promotions
following that we have social B this
tool offers the ability to schedule and
publish posts engage with followers and
track analytics finally we have social
drift this tool helps you get more
Instagram followers by using artificial
intelligence to engage with users who
are likely to follow you and this was
all for today's session hope he has
found it informative and helpful if you
like this session then like share and
subscribe if you have any question you
can drop them in the comment section
below thanks for watching and stay tuned
for more from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here